wasquehal à une quarantaine de
kilomètres de la capitale bogota était à
portée de la guérilla des farc à son
apogée de puissance à la fin des années
90 elle a déposé les armes il ya cinq
ans
la paix quoique imparfaite a bien changé
le paysage politique colombien on peut
se dire de gauche sans être soupçonné de
sympathie avec des terroristes et depuis
trois ans les colombiens ne se sont pas
gênés pour exprimer leur colère contre
le gouvernement sortant ce fonctionnaire
municipal prévoit une plus forte
mobilisation à spider man des cas la
rotation ca bastia est couvert
cette élection promet un vrai changement
[Musique]
tous expliquent la popularité inédite du
candidat de gauche gustavo petro dans un
pays gouverné par la droite depuis 200
ans ancien guérillero du m-19 député
sénateur maire de bogota il a une longue
carrière politique et a réussi à former
une coalition de gauche le pacte
historique
le choix dit il c'est encore plus de
corruption de violence et de faim ou
bien changer la colombie
le trouble fête et ce riche homme
d'affaires de 77 ans ancien maire de
bouc à la manga rodolfo hernández ses
adversaires le décrivent comme un
populiste deux types de races trempe où
jaillit repose sonar ou du brésil en
moins explosif mais très présent comme
eux dans les médias sociaux ce qui va
faire la différence et le taux de
participation traditionnellement très
faible en colombie le vote des jeunes
sera probablement décisif
jean michel lebrun traits du canada
wasquehal